I'm actually not going to talk about
icon today I always talk about icons and
I always write about icons and I'm not
going to talk about the Harvey I'm going
to talk about stories the talk that I
was supposed that I won that was also
give was called encountering God in
story and image but as I was preparing
the to talk the one I'll give today and
tomorrow I decided to put them together
they're kind of fused together and so
images will come tomorrow in my talk and
today I'm going to bring in some of
things River releases ideas into the
talk I'm going to give today so let's
start with a statement the start of the
statement that is the world is made of
stories I mean of course the world is
made of things as well but mostly I
would say most significantly the world
is held together by stories you know as
Orthodox Christians we say we believe
that we can encounter God anywhere and
in everything that is the language of
st. Gregory Palamas
the uncreated divine energies are hiding
behind phenomena we believe in the
wonderful frames given us given to us by
st. John the theologian and expanded by
then Maximus that the logos of things
everything in the world is created as a
hidden purpose as a hidden logo and all
things are connected and they're united
by their logos to each other and
ultimately to the divine logos in love
when we hear such phrases I mean the
first times I started to hear this type
of language I have to admit that it was
easy just for it to sounds like kind of
esoteric mumbo-jumbo you know has that
strange sound because my here's my first
thought and I can I can understand that
you know and sometimes it look like
something so obscure that we you know we
have to just make that leap of faith to
believe it
but really and get rid of that really if
you love beyond the technical wording
this way of seeing the world is simply
how the world presents itself to us in
fact these truth about logos about
divine energies are so close to us that
they permeate all our experiences and it
does begin with space and not to space
as this mental belief in something but I
would say faith as a commitment to the
indivisible and this space will help us
experience how the invisible not only
transcends the visible but it also is
the thing that holds the visible world
together so how the world and the
invisible hold is visible together it
can actually be quite simple and stories
are one of the most needed examples in
our daily experience of how the
invisible holds divisible together a
story is a series of facts facts chosen
among an indefinite amount of possible
facts these facts are characters are
places they're objects that all interact
in a string of events threaded together
in a pattern of meaning and the pattern
of a story is the invisible part of a
story the pattern can be found in the
individual elements of a story or even
the accumulated elements of a story but
it appears as the reason why those
things are brought together and the
pattern is an arbitrary it imposes
itself on us to our intuition by how
much it is meaningful to us we know
something is a story because it awakens
our humanity because it captures our
attention
so like imagine imagine a series of
events okay the stages happened this
morning so this morning I got off I put
on one sock and then I scratch my nose I
breathe three times and my heartbeat
about 20 times then I put on the other
sock I coughed a little at least a few
times I glanced at the belt on the chair
I breathed another two times and whose
board I mean although there's clearly
there's clearly a character in what I
just said and there are events in the
description but that's not a story
I mean it's boring if I kept going like
that I'd have people walking out of the
room so you're considerated and let me
give you another series of events event
so last Sunday morning I got up and we
were late for church so I getting ready
I go to put on my socks but looking into
the drawer I realized that all of them
were in the wash so here I am trying to
panic I'm running around the house
trying to find a clean pair of socks and
after another five minutes I'm at the
point of giving up all hope is lost and
then thinking okay I'm going to have to
dive into the hamper and get it's into
danger detox
well I start to wonder would it be
considered cross-dressing if I borrowed
my wife's box
and so as I'm Shane shamefully sifting
through my wife's box you know looking
over my shoulder hoping she won't see me
and wondering like am I gonna have to
confess this me if I'm gonna confess
this is it because you know I'm
cross-dressing is because I'm taking
some anyway so as I'm sifting through my
wife thoughts what do i come upon a pair
of my own socks that were right there
you know put there by some mischievous
elf some might a miracle you know that's
more of a story I mean of course you
could say that it's a trivial story
it's a very localized story that could
only be understood by modern people and
that's true but the pattern of the story
the invisible structure which make one
see that it is actually a story and not
just a random accumulation of facts
well that pattern is something that is
truly universal
it's something which is written in human
consciousness I would say that it's
actually a mould of human consciousness
now in the little in the little square
of starts I just told you when sees the
loss of something important
sauce in this case because I come from
Quebec and in the winter you don't go
without socks it's not going to happen
but more far-reaching stories will have
more significant term so what's lost
could be the Holy Grail or with laws
could be Sauron rings or it could be the
paradise of Adam and Eve
and then comes the panic all hope is law
but it's in the very descent into chaos
and inversion that the thing is finally
found by some surprise so for the Grail
is found in the castle of the wounded
Fisher King for the ring in the dark
cave of the riddling monster golem and
the law of paradise is recaptured on the
cross for death and division are
transformed into glory
but in my benign missing sock case the
solution came as I'm sifting through my
wife's soft drawer which is not chaotic
at all by the way she'll be listening to
this yeah all right of course there are
some stories that don't follow these
patterns very well and those stories
they just kind of fall to the wayside
and The Forgotten I mean all of those
how my day went story or the novel that
you find the discount bin or those TV
shows that gets canceled after one
season but those stories that embody
Universal patterns in the terms that
have wider importance well those stories
last they enter our consciousness and
they support our identity then you come
to this underlying web of references
with which we encounter the world
and that's really important because we
all have an underlying web of references
with which we functions and that's part
of what the Bible does that's one of the
points of all these stories we tell the
creation the flood the life of Abraham
is descendants the kings the prophets
all of that is a giant pattern and it's
part of this cosmic web of logos that
holds the universe together and prevent
it from fragmenting into isolated
particular events this fragmentation is
a process which leads to chaos and even
the reduction of these particularities
and the statistical possibility I mean
just look at where particle physics have
run as they cut up the world the smaller
and smaller discrete point and we need
to guard our story because the chaos
that's described in Genesis when it says
in the beginning God created heaven and
earth and the earth was empty and void
that primordial chaos which precedes the
light and sounds of logos that still
lingers hasn't gone anywhere still
lingers at this bottomless ambiguity
under and around the ordered world under
the pattern that stories give us chaos
is held at bay by the edifice that logos
establishes to hold creation together so
like I said at the beginning I'm going
to be speaking of SendGrid
st. gregory of nyssa tomorrow as we
explore his amazing book the life of
Moses but I want to bring him already
into the conversation today because he
gives us the key to some of the
questions some of these things that I've
been bringing up about pattern so in his
book st. Gregory at some point the
culminating point of his book he
describes the ascent of Moses unto the
Sinai to receive the law given to him by
God and also to receive the pad
of the tabernacle so first Gregory says
molded leaves behind the base of the
mountain and it's separated from all
those too weak for the ascent then as he
rises higher in a descent he hears the
sounds of trumpets thereupon he slips
into the inner sanctuary of divine
knowledge and he does not remain there
but he passes on to the Tabernacle not
made with an for truly this is the limit
that reaches that someone reaches was
elevated to such a sense so God shows
moses pattern of the tabernacle which
he's going to he's going to have built
as the center of Israelite worship and
in his interpretation of this event
st. Gregory does some amazing things she
speaks in somewhat hushed tones of that
spiritual pattern that was encountered
by Moses as quote an archetype so that
he might reproduce in a handmade
structure that marble not made with
hands unquote and that Gregory almost
hesitates and you can feel it in the
text but then he goes on quote we say
that Moses was instructed by a type in
the mystery of the tabernacle which
encompasses the universe that Tabernacle
would be Christ who is the power and the
wisdom of God when his own nature was
not made with hands it's capable of
being made when it became necessary for
this tab
we erected among them the the same
Tabernacle is in a way both
unfashionable but created in having
receive this material composition and
worried that we might be offended to see
God himself compared to the tabernacle
I think Gregory tells us to not be
afraid quote for the power which
encompasses the universe in which lives
the fullness of divinity the common
protector of all who encompasses
everything within himself is rightly
called tabernacle unquote and so here we
have an amazing description of a pattern
encountered beyond the inner sanctuary
of divine knowledge by Moses it's an
architect an architectural pattern which
is Christ and contains the universe
within itself now think about that for a
second Moses is ascending a mountain but
then Gregory talks of an inner sanctuary
of divine knowledge that is he's using
this general notion of a place right the
sanctuary is a holy place the inner
sanctuary is the inner holy place which
is equivalent to the Holy of Holies of
the tabernacle itself the place where
the high priest could enter and where
the divine glory the presence of God
descended on the Ark of the Covenant
until the top of this mountain is this
book that Moses is ascending is put in
comparison is made analogical to the
sanctuary and we know later in our in
our tradition that the human heart the
the person's heart will play the same
analogical function as that Holy of
Holies where the human must entered
and illumination so then moving beyond
the holy of holies encounter the
invisible pattern of that very sanctuary
which was surpassed so st. Gregory then
goes to describe the different aspects
of the tabernacle how the different
aspects represent different aspects of
Christ but also Christ Church and so
what ends up happening to us as we look
at this is we see these these patterns
within patterns so the structure of
Israel Tabernacle which was going to be
built and be the center of Israel worth
of Israel's worship is also the mountain
which moments ascended it's also the
person of the life of Christ and then
becomes the structure of the church
itself and all its members and at the
same time it's an image of our own
experience as we approach God as our
only fears as we enter our own heart to
find illumination and so it's something
like that the vision of the prophet
Daniel I don't know if you know decision
where he looked at the divine chariot
which was carrying the presence of God
and he saw wheels would within wheels
within wheels and so this these patterns
that lock together and create like a
kamesh that makes us understand what
things are referring to so okay what I
said might or it still sound a bit
obscure to everybody okay so hopefully
I'm going to bring it more into a more
applicable way and and to be honest it
is way is way far beyond my capacity
capacity to resume this universal
pattern I'm not Moses than I am not
think Reger II and I have definitely not
the divine darkness but I think like
most people like most of us here I mean
we have these intimations we have these
moments these glimpses of some of the
smaller aspects or some of the smaller
patterns which embeds themselves to the
larger one which constitutes its
infinite tabernacle so hopefully I what
I can do with you today is it maybe
provoke some intimation or give a little
glimpse and I think the only proof of
way to do this and our context is to do
it the way the fathers didn't and it's
the way think Gregory did it and it's to
show how everything how this whole
pattern of how all the patterns of
meaning points to Christ and I think
that that is the surest way for any of
us to encounter God in stories and so we
come back to a familiar territory
because for Christians you know the
traditional vision of the Old Testament
is that all the stories point to Christ
right all the Old Testament stories
contain prototypes of Christ that urine
a it tells us that quote is anyone
therefore read the scriptures with
attention he will find in them an
account of Christ for Christ is the
treasure which was hid in the field the
treasure hid in Scripture this Christ as
he was pointed out by means of types and
parables
I told from a theological and even even
an adjuster melodical point of view that
makes total sense right all the
instances of meaning extend from and
point to the origin of meaning the
origin of everything which is the divine
logos that pattern not made with hands
who entered through his incarnation into
the cosmic story so to become not only
the origins of the story but it's very
Center and in fact as anybody who reads
the narrative parts of the Old Testament
simply as storage you know rather than
attempting to decompose them into
competing mini narratives of religious
and political struggle like a lot of the
scholars want to do if you pay attention
to those stories you can't help but
notice that each story is like an
extreme facet of something you know
these stories in the Old Testaments are
like these sharp slivers that come
together into a smooth whole and brought
together in Christ so as an example I
want to give you the story of I getting
used one of the major stories I stolen
that I think everybody knows is the
story of Cain and Abel so once it's hell
I want to see how one of the ways that
we can see this pattern appear in to
serve Cain and Abel so Cain is an
agriculturist cane grows his food and
Cain is also the founder of the first
city in the Bible he is the founder of
the first city and his descendants
actually all the aspects of culture all
the aspects of sedentary culture come
from the descendants of Cain in the
genealogy of Genesis and his brother
Abel on the other hand he's a shepherd
so he's a nomad
so when they sacrifice
what does Kane offer Cain offers to God
the product of agriculture so when they
sacrifice Cain offers the product of
Agriculture and Abel offers from a swap
the two sacrifices are unequal right
Cain sacrifice is rejected by God and
Cain kills his brother Cod and
resentment so we all know that story
very well now if we look at that story I
mean the first if you look at that store
try to look at that story in life of
Christ we is the first thing that would
tend to come out is that we would say
okay what Christ is of course Abel
that's the Good Shepherd and Christ is
the innocence who dives at the
of the jealous establishment make sense
what Christ stories like as you look a
little bit deeper we actually realize
that Christ is also pain because Christ
is the sower and the Reaper and Christ
is called the son of an artisan and he
is the firstborn we can say that he is
truly his brother's keeper so Christ
unites and reconciled in his very person
that first and primordial conflict of
humanity then if we push that point even
further we realize that Christ takes the
sacrifice of Cain the product of the
earth
like bread and wine and he United to the
sacrifice of Abel a flesh and blood and
he makes them one so this takes us to
the Eucharist it takes us into
pretension into community but if we if
we start to ponder on communion we know
that it can't stop there because it was
just the story of Cain and Abel that
gave us the key to communion ie
it might be enough to blow our mind
already but it's more it's always so
much more Christ's offering also takes
the show grant which in the tabernacle
was offered in the hidden holy place and
he unites it with the animal sacrifice
which was offered in the outer court and
community is not just about sacrifice
right it's the fruit of the tree of
knowledge and the Tree of Life hanging
from the ultimate tree which is the
cross it is the hospitality of Abraham
uniting us to the angels the offering of
Melchizedek the strange dream Joseph
interprets in prison
it contains bread which is a staple food
with wine which is a euphoric drink
did you nice meat which in the Old
Testament was offered up to God
and eaten by those sacrificing and blood
which in the Old Testament was never
consumed but was placed on the frame of
the door sprinkled on the outside of the
altar the outside of the mercy seat and
poured out on the ground yet it is now
part of the totality which the divine
mysteries make available to us and on
that last example that both my mind and
I could spend all day
pointing at intimations of the divine
mysteries based on Old Testament
examples and I would always find one
more example of what the mystery
contains and what it also transformed
and transcended and strangely
establishes at the same time so just
like in the example I just gave you of
Cain and Abel the stories in the Old
Testament and other important stories
they never attain to Christ that is if
you look at Christ and his own story
they always exceed those stories but
because of that fact Christ also becomes
that place where all the stories come
together and we can get information of
logos from all types of stories I
believe when we approached them with
humility and and the patterns which
reveal themselves to us and those
stories can be like many many epiphanies
and you can and we can experience them
on a very existential level I mean I
have been brought many times to tears by
the beauty and the power of the sudden
connection no you're you're meditating
on a story that you've known your whole
life that your parents told you when you
were a child and all of a sudden it's
like a bolt of lightning you know
becomes transparent and you see that
hidden pearl that it contains so Christ
is the key to Old Testament stories but
as the incarnation of the logos I
I believe he's the key to all story I
believe that in him the major patterns
of universal storytelling find their
summit you know that I admit is a bold
statement and and I can't extensively
prove it today but what I want to do is
I'm going to give you one example one
major example and hopefully it will give
all all of us that little spark that
impetus to meditate on other stories and
other patterns which exist in
storytelling so the example I've chosen
to use is the common theme and
storytelling which is called the Kutta
boxes and the cotta boxes is the descent
into the underworld by the way that I
hinted to it in my story of stalks at
the beginning that when the little
descent into the underworld so you know
scholars have often pointed to the fact
that the Christian vision of the
harrowing of of Hades of Christ
descending into Hades to free its
captive is a theme that's taken from
world myth and often as is common with
scholars there's a tone of smugness
smugness when they communicate that to
us you know that oh you know Christians
you think you're so special with the
story of a descendant to Hades well you
know it's a story that's been around for
thousands of years so and so for them it
it points not only point to the fact of
how unoriginal Christianity is but also
to how untrue it is so I have to be I
have to be honest I mean that line of
argumentation has always baffled me I
mean I remember in my first year of
college one of one of my opening college
traumatism Jew with colors and there
would be several more I remember there
was some grad student who was giving a
lecture on flood narrative and her point
in her talk was basically this that
there are flood narratives and pretty
much every single
culture and what that means is that the
Bible isn't true and I remember when I
was like 17 or 18 I was already baffled
and I was being told that there is a
pattern of storytelling which exists in
almost every culture on all continents I
mean it is either the oldest memory held
in unison by all men or there is some
mental structure that is so deeply
embedded in the human Constitution that
it manifests itself through this
universal image of an all destroying
flood and the reaction to that awesome
reality is to tell people that the Bible
is in truth it is baffling so let's get
back to our kata botches so selective
flood merit is the descendants of Hades
is nearly everywhere in Mesopotamia and
Egypt in the Mediterranean but in Asia
as well Africa the Americas and in the
West we're most familiar of course with
the stories that come from Greek and
Roman myths and in those stories we
found we find these visits to the
underworld for example we know the story
Odysseus on his voyage home who enters
the underworld and summons the prophet
Tiresias
or the story of the hero Aeneas who goes
down through the underworld and then up
if you will anticipating Dante and
travels to Elysium the land of the
Blessed where he encounters his dead
father and there are also stories of
salvation from Hades I mean the
salvation usually includes someone from
the living or some God that descends
into Hades in order to find someone else
in order to save someone who's stucked
there someone who got trapped there for
some reason
so in this pattern we find the story of
Theseus and peeresses those two fellows
they descended into the underworld
because they wanted to steal his bride
Persephone and then they made the
mistake of sitting down
the underworld so don't sit down in
health that's a life story that's a life
lesson that you need to know a
resurrection being standing up again so
don't sit down London school so they get
stuck there for a little while and then
Herakles when he's going in his voyage
down into he's going to to capture the
the dog Cerberus the three-headed dog
who guards this is a Hades
when he goes down there then he goes and
he frees his friends Theseus but sadly
peer-assisted stuff to insurance so so
as I mentioned in Christianity as we as
everybody here knows we have the
tradition of the harrowing of Hades
which of course is the basis of this
icon the icon of the honest answers so
Christ upon his death on the cross
descends into death and the images and
the narrative around the story
scholars have noticed that it's in a
recording exam it just repeats the cut
about this pattern that we've examined
and so obviously it is just one more
example of that Universal min or is it
and there's been a lot of discussion
about this and very provocative scholars
like James Fraser at the beginning of
the 20th century he kind of started this
but other scholars have tackled it like
young and Joseph Campbell and they've
all attempted to show the similarity
between Christ's stories and the other
ancient minutes and you know and then
they're discussed and debated and
they're argued about and you find
Christian apologists who are fighting
against these people you know as if to
defend the accusation that you know that
Christ's story is an analogical the
other ancient story but for me you know
I I'm actually willing to be extremely
generous with these scholars I am you
know like if you if you just take the
very broad pattern of someone that goes
down into the
the world or even down into the water or
into a cave you know to encounter
someone or to retrieve something to look
for a treasure like Aladdin torches to
save someone like Horus did Osiris
you know like Heracles Safety's is
although we couldn't say for
appearance's I'm willing to give it all
to them and say yes that pattern exists
and it is one of the most basic
structures of human consciousness but
then you have to ask what does Christ
story do to that pattern you see these
scholars like like Frasier and young and
even Campbell they have a actually
ignored the story that Christians
actually tell they'd ignore the whole
story but it is false that Christians
believe Christ travelled to the
underworld and then came out first of
all we believe that Christ died with
everything that implies he was not
visiting death he united himself to
death he took death within himself and
the extra biblical traditions we have
these images of hey is rejoicing right
rejoicing thinking he has won because he
has taken everything in only to be
surprised and then did Christ just go
down into Hades to save someone and then
come back no but that's not the story we
tell by bringing God into death we
believe as Christians in the words of
the Apostle that Christ abolished death
completely we say it over and over at
tadka we recent than john chrysostom
homily every year Christ is risen and
you O death are annihilated the evil
ones are cast down the Angels rejoice
life is liberated Christ is risen and
the tomb is emptied of its dead Oh death
where is your sting
I mean even peeresses is gone now even
before you believe it or not even before
you begin to ponder the insane paradox
that such a statement brings about we
just look at it in terms of a story if
you just look at it how that story
engages that pattern that ancient
pattern of cata boxes of that descent
into Hades we find an example of what
Christ's story does to all stories what
he does to all things that he all at
once transcends even obliterates the
pattern yet simultaneously he
universalized it connects it grounded
illuminates it the pattern of the
descent and return from Hades is both
transcended and fulfilled at the same
time and that Transfiguration and it's
not only that but suddenly all these old
stories are increasingly seen through
Christ and one of the hilarious ironies
of the anti-christian 20th century is
that these scholars like Frazer for
example who use all the ancient myths
you know the so-called dying God to
trivialize Christianity you realize that
he's looking at all those myths through
the lens of Christ the event of
Christianity was so ground-shaking that
so many of those that oppose it even
today they can't help but do that
looking through the glasses that
Christianity gave us and so the
encounter of the divine and stories is
something which can happen anywhere
anytime but in order to experience this
or I must always be focused on Christ
and we must progressively strip away our
passion now I know a few people even
maybe here
well they listen to this talk and felt
maybe a bit uneasy you know and think
that maybe I'm just proposing some
intellectual game for people to play but
encountering Christ is sort and story is
a work of our entire being
because in pondering and meditating on
the story of the Christ what we realize
and then what I realize is that we all
have these we all have a little Christ
and I think that all Christians do and
we have this small limited Christ which
is actually an image of us and in this
little image of Christ you want to see
the highest thing because it is an image
of us and that's a lot easier and some
of us might be attached to certain
aspects of Christ story so so I mean you
meet people who are attached to for
example this the infant blessing sermon
on the model aspect of Christ and we
want to see in that the highest thing
other people are attached to the
denouncing hypocrisy and laying it out
as it is facet of Christ others to
Christ as a ruler and the judge of the
world still others to the teacher of
truth or Christ as the healer and still
others as the self-sacrificing aspect of
Christ of this innocent victim of a
corrupt establishment and the list goes
on and on and each of these facets of
Christ are good but if we take them
alone without committing ourselves in
faith to the whole in those facets we
can hide our own passions and so for
example those who do not who prefer the
denouncing hypocrisy facet of Christ
might resent Authority those who prefer
the teacher of truth might ignore the
significance of Christ
praising Samaritans who were the
heretics of his
in order to encounter God in story you
must first renew our intelligence but we
must also slowly let go of our passions
our pride and as we do the story of
Christ opens itself to us and we will
see more of him in it I mean I'm always
amazed every time I go through the
gospel and knock down and I'm like how
is it that I didn't notice this before
it's like I've read it 30 times why is
it that this little thing that Christ
says has never stuck into my memory and
it's usually because it doesn't fit what
I think Christ is and it just shatters
you every time and you you have to
reconsider that know Christ is bigger
than what you'll what you think any
bigger is it you'll always think he's
bigger than everything and I think that
as we do that more of Christ will appear
to us from Old Testament stories and
even the light of Christ will start to
shine through the world story in the
capacity that each story has to manifest
that light enough and I'm not saying
that all stories are good at their
specific I mean obviously not there are
many evil things and stories just as
there are in people but one is always
surprised to encounter a seed of truth
in the strangest place so sometimes
hidden deep down in the right surrounded
by weeds it might be behind all the veil
behind all the coverings we sometimes
are surprised to encounter this divine
spark and so that's my curtains for
everyone today thank you
you
[Applause]